foreign
exciting announcement for the past year
I have been investigating an incident
known as the southern television
Interruption a bizarre event where
mysterious voice broke onto an English
television station it's been unsolved
for 45 years but I have made some
developments I'm now ready to make my
research public and it's going to take
the form of a podcast series here's the
trailer
this story is not a work of Science
Fiction
everything you're about to hear is true
the Rhodesian nationalist leader Bishop
Abel musaraba has accepted Mr Smith's
offer to negotiate for southern
television a TV station based in the
south of England November 26 1977 was a
day like any other until 5 PM when this
happened
[Music]
the broadcast had been hijacked by a
deep echoey voice the speaker identified
themselves as vrylon and claimed to be
calling from outer space
[Music]
the message lasted for six more minutes
but then
it was gone I understand that viewers in
some parts of the region are receiving a
breakthrough in sand nobody came forward
to claim responsibility for this event
to this day no one knows who was behind
it but that's where I come in I am going
to investigate what really happened an
unravel an incident that was the very
first of its kind join me on this UFO
Odyssey it's gonna get weird uh as you
call it he says a certain situation
rather I'm a dangerous one you could say
that this is fraud of course but I would
rather interpreted it as a genuine
attempt to reveal important religious
messages to people it was real to take
the piece of the establishment 45 years
later I am going to answer the
unanswered to extract that information
you should actually read his book it's
called Ori behind whatever motive there
was for what happened in 1977 it was an
amazing event I am so am I speaking to
villain yes you are great see you
from the 28th of November the
interruption will be available to
download wherever you get your podcasts
two episodes dropping weekly
[Music]
who or what was behind
the interruption
well there we are a trailer for my very
first documentary series I cannot wait
for this to come out Monday the 28th of
November is the launch be sure to pencil
that in long time viewers of the channel
might be Vaguely Familiar with the story
it's the topic of one of my earliest
videos but at eight minutes long it only
scratches the surface trust me a link to
it should be on screen somewhere or down
in the description you'll also find a
link to stack the award-winning podcast
company who I'm making this with they
make other awesome shows like Jackie the
Ripper boom and Jack mates happy hour
and now the interruption stay tuned in
the meantime I'll return to regular
broadcasting more YouTube videos on the
way I look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye